as our weather warms up county leaders  are warning people about the dangers of  leaving children in a hunt car this car  was set up with a thermometer outside  the Smith's grocery store at Rainbow and  windmill a child's temperature can rise  two or three degrees each minute when  left in a hot vehicle from March through  May EMS workers in Clark County were  called out for 102 times for unattended  children gene marsala is the director of  safe kids at sunrise Children's Hospital  she says as so many deal with disrupted  routines it is extra important to  double-check your surroundings and just  pay attention the concern with that is  that we really only have 50% of cars out  on the roads so that shows me that there  are more incidents happening because  more people are staying at home in  Nevada is is illegal to leave a child  under the age of seven unattended in a  car for any reason  [Music]